[Music]
it's the minivans you need to watch out
for
unmarked but you know who's inside
people have almost three months
experience of this now
and they know who you need to run
fastest from
these people behind there they are not
general right police
they are so called those who fight or
crime organized crime yes but generally
they're a lot more aggressive than the
general right police for some reasons so
everybody's got to be careful
with them in particular sometimes though
you just don't see them
across the road a police unit appears as
if from nowhere
another random detention of hundreds
today
[Music]
this monday was supposed to be a
nationwide strike
[Applause]
a few short videos from inside factory
walls showed that some workers did join
but officially the nation's factories
were working as normal
outside the minsk tractor factory we met
a group come to show
solidarity for striking workers we
realized that
not many people support their strike
but we know that every
action helps us to find freedom for our
country
students though have less to lose
they've only ever known lukashenko as
president
and they want that to change this is the
second time that police have come down
this street towards the students but
then decided
to back down quite what their strategy
is i'm not sure but they have made
some arrests already today there's a
pensioners march
due soon and last week they sprayed tear
gas at them so we'll see how that pans
out
our kids are the best the students have
come to join
and they in turn chant thank you to the
pensioners for their commitment to the
cause
[Music]
this time the police let them all walk
freely through the centre of town
thousands of them a march that passed
uneventfully
and once the crowds had dispersed a few
brave stragglers decided to give the
riot police a piece of their mind
i told them that they're standing there
now and smiling at us and yesterday they
were beating our children
they were beating our grandchildren not
a single one of them is clean
each one of them bit someone during
their service
and outside the police stations is the
evidence of that
families and friends waiting anxiously
in the cold for any word on their loved
ones
news they'll be lucky to get
dynamagnay sky news minsk